tensions between Israel and Hamas is not
slowing down Palestine it's such a mess
right now that 400 people got killed in
a hospital you just recently did history
of Hamas hisbah and Isis you're going to
leave basically a lot of people alive
who subsequently you know hate Israel so
so pbd can you please do a similar 25
minute video clip with the citations and
everything this is US Department of
Justice it's a government website for
for every Hamas member that you kill how
many did you create mhm and and if Theon
we know the name Hamas Hamas would not
have existed without Theon alul
greetings with peace welcome to the dean
show we got a very special guest in the
dean show Studio we're going to be
talking a a lot around what's happening
current
events and without further
Ado I love you you're when I was ready
to talk about it I would only talk to
you I was explaining
how much respect I have for the Fai of
[Music]
Islam Dr Shadi how are you alhamdulillah
very good Salam and and thank you for uh
having me over how you been very good
very good been watching your uh program
for uh uh decades nowah seems like it's
since I was in college but Mah you kept
it up and it's kept keeps growing and
growing it's good to see it
alhamdulillah flourishing and advancing
thank you thank you alhamdulillah uh so
I watched a uh particular video that you
made it was very interesting you just
recently did history of Hamas hisbah and
Isis I recommend people watch it I'm
holding up on my iPad US Department of
Justice what about the history of
Israeli terrorist organizations so pbd
can you please do a similar 25 minute
video clip with the citations and
everything this is US Department of
Justice it's a government
website uh outlining Terror out of Zion
all of this is started because of
terrorism performed by zionists the eron
we know the name Hamas Hamas would not
have existed without the eron in other
words all the resistance all of this
resistance all of this hatred all of
this grievance would not have existed
without organizations like the ha Theon
how is the hag different from what
hisbah is today and you actually sent a
message to someone who um I got to uh
spend a little bit of time with a very
nice man by the name of Patrick B David
and for our viewing audience who doesn't
know I'm I'm going to just jump into
this clip right now sure and it revolves
around this video that he made regarding
the history of Hamas heah and uh Isis
tensions between Israel and Hamas is not
slowing down Palestine it's such a mess
right now that 400 people got killed in
a hospital where one side is saying
Israel did it the other does saying
Hamas did it President Biden had to go
to meet with Netanyahu and have a
conversation even in a meeting he says
well with the recent events that
happened we're pretty confident that it
was Hamas that did it but we're looking
into it it's that you didn't do it like
that's what Joe Biden said to Netanyahu
in his face which was kind of
interesting and then to the point 2.2
million people we're talking about the
Gaza Strip one of the most densely
populated places in the world 75,000
people live within a square mile no food
no water no electricity no hospital
supplies since the night they've had
none of that they're being pushed down
imagine the viruses the sickness all of
this stuff has taking place at the same
time Russia's now getting involved
hezbollah's commenting Iran's been
involved us ascending 2 so you saw this
video I saw the video and more
importantly I had seen a lot of his
other clips and he came across to me as
a very fair-minded Guy and because he
seems like a guy that you could talk to
um that's when I felt like hold on a
second he's telling us in this clip he's
telling us all about who is Hamed
who was hisbah uh who is Isis even okay
and then uh at the end of the clip he's
saying listen we got to be level-headed
and use our Our Fair judgment and not be
uh attached to our tribe only and only
support our people only well if I bring
these two
together is I should request of you to
to to to look at the whole history and
realize that if you think these are
terrorist groups and I'm not going we're
not going to debate that part right now
but Israel was initiated and expanded
through terroristic
means uh before being an official Nation
by almost in a sense bullying the
British into uh reenacting their B for
declaration which many people don't
realize they took it back the the
British actually took it back the B for
declaration and released a white paper
that said no no no no we're not having a
Jewish state only 75,000 Jews and and
then the rest is gu going to be a
regular State mixed with whoever lives
there yeah the hag is a terrorist group
they were meant to defend uh the Jews
they started as a militia in Palestine
and then they started blowing things
up right they started blowing things up
including the the the cap the base where
the British were so by any legal
definition it's also terroristic group
so if the call is to be fair and
balanced about things then look at the
whole whole history of the conflict not
come you know you walk on the scene and
you see one guy punching another guy
that's not the whole scene that's not
the whole you want to see the whole
picture now you need to see the whole
picture and I would only you know talk
to him in the sense that you know make a
video back in the sense that I believed
him to be like a a fair guy and it's not
just that now this is coming from I mean
this is a you're a religious community
leader now you're someone who's a
resident scholar yeah uh in New Jersey
in New Jersey yeah so you're a community
leader there and now you're actually
sending this he's actually getting now
Muslim he got Muslims who are watching
him Community leaders actually sending
him messages I mean it's a big step
forward for Patrick he's uh yeah I mean
he's getting Community the attention of
the Muslim leaders well he's definitely
he definitely got Muslims attention a
couple times uh it's a good thing it's a
good thing he got my
attention uh with a clip that he said
some things about Muslims being the ones
who who are going to have families in
the future yeah they're standing up to
moral causes they stand up to to to for
the honor of their messenger mhm peace
be upon him and he had a very respectful
things to say really nice things to say
about Muslims yes I said oh I want to
listen to this guy right start listening
more and more and his coverage on the
Palestine thing he he's always he has
a one of the members of his show M but
he's only that member of the show is an
Israeli citizen I believe he's always
going to Israel he he's only given him
one
side right even in this video right it
was there wasn't looked like he was
trying to bash Muslims or anything like
that he's not so agenda oriented MH uh
and so I felt like you know he's
somebody who should also make a video on
uh the past now I don't know if he can
uh people have allegiances they have
friends and no one's without bias right
and so um that's where I felt that uh he
should really highlight
both sides if it's really truly about
being fair let's go back to the two
groups the ha and the more extreme group
The eron that's a good point because he
in the video he talked about the um
resistance group Hamas giving the
history of the Isis and then hasah okay
so what you're saying is okay good and
you were in the video you're talking
about okay you're giving some certain
facts and data and whatnot yeah now show
The Other Side the flip side now the
other ones who actually are because of
these groups it started these groups is
that right that's exactly it so you
you're when you have the the the smaller
group the embattled group misbehaving
even just to take uh to accept the
argument right they're are misbehaving
they're only taking hostages and doing
these attacks let's accept that as a
hypothetical uh I'm not saying that
that's not true that that didn't happen
but people may uh um dispute yeah the
exact details of how those hostages were
treated blah blah blah but let's say
that that small embattled group is doing
all these acts that the best thing I
heard is that is the secondary infection
the little guy when he fights punches
back that's a secondary infection that
can only be triggered by a primary
infection right the source of why that
person is frustrated in the first place
right so if if if why go into a house
and a kid is misbehaving children aren't
born misbehaving chances are are he's
been treated wrong some way in some way
shape and form right nobody goes in and
sees a kid misbehaving and just says
it's the kids fa it's got to be the
parents like ignoring him the parents
not treating him right someone's
bothering him in school and the parents
not protecting him it's got to be
something so in that world the
Palestinians are the embattled small
group of people right they got no
weapons they got no recognition in the
world no one's helping them they don't
have opportunities in life they're
miserable in their life they're
especially RZA so when they're acting
out now there must be a primary
infection why don't we look at the
primary cause the root of the whole
matter mhm and that you can't help
yourself but go into history you have to
go back to 19 to the 40s mhm nobody
should say oh let's not go back in the
history no we have to go back to the
history when do these groups start now
these uh the ones you mentioned and how
come we never hear of these groups
really you don't hear them in the
mainstream media you don't you always
hear the other ones that you mentioned
but I most people don't even hear hagana
or and yeah hag Aragon is now the IDF
and it's been vanilla that's now the IDF
that's now the IDF okay so the hag so
you are you saying so uh the second one
urgan they were actually what classified
as they were like a breakoff of the
hagana and but smaller but more extreme
okay bombed Arab Villages bombed Arabs
killed Arabs and and the Arab militias
were fighting back too yeah but they
were both fighting each other while the
British were busy with World War II and
they were classified Terror
organizations Terror organizations yeah
and and I in that video I put up a book
that's on cia.gov yeah right you quoted
that was another thing that come you
quoted actually the government agencies
now so the cia.gov has put out a book or
they're sharing a book on their website
when you look on ca.gov and you're
looking for information on the ha this
book comes up and it classifies them as
a terroristic group mhm right how are
they a terroristic group well they had
no official recognition like they were
not recognized as a government uh as a
government they were not recognized as
anything they're not legally allowed to
be aggressing on anybody yes yet they
did and they aggressed on the British
and David benan who's the founder of of
Israel uh uh the first president of
Israel he said directly to the British
when when in Europe we fight the Nazis
together we're allies here in P
Palestine all right we're adversaries MH
until you give us the state cuz the
whole thing is in British control now
and the British were influenced to
create a city to to create a nation in
Palestine uh mind you the reason that
they wanted to create a state in sorry a
state not a City a state for Jews in
Palestine one of the reasons was that
one of them was a Christian one of the
Lords what was his name can't remember
his name one of the Lords in England was
a Christian and believed it was his
religious duty to set up uh the Kingdom
of Israel again mhm so that religious
part of it always comes in yeah right so
he was like one of the first
evangelicals he was British so the
balfor
Declaration was the uh famous document
that said we're going to make a Jewish
State then they took it back the Arabs
got upset and they took it back and they
said all right no Jewish State you're
going to have a regular country
regular secular country 75,000 Jews
maximum and that was called the white
paper where they took it back and that's
where the hag and the Aron got working
and they started launching attacks on
the British physical attacks bombs
hotels 90 people dead here 30 people
dead there is that what it the King
David King David Hotel so is this
conspiracy theory or no no this is fact
these are facts this are all fact it's
all fact and they're listed as terrorist
organizations yeah in time the British
caved in and they said all right here
take a country and this is part is
Palestine this part is wa but I thought
there was no negotiating with terrorists
y That's supposed to be right and they
they capitulated yeah completely uh to
the demands and really what pushed it
over the top was uh sympathy because now
Hitler did what he did right and now we
need to give you know the Jews need some
break from that and they need some Safe
Haven from that so that really pushed it
over the top in terms of public opinion
mhm right so they get the St they they
they get the country and here's where um
things really start to to to become
nasty and I recommend everybody watch a
movie called
1948 creation and conflict 19 1948
creation conflict is this on YouTube
it's on YouTube it's about 1948 creation
and conflict creation and conflict I'm
not if I'm not mistaken that's a title
but if you type it in you'll get the
exact
title and up to now you're like okay
look the British they they they they
took the
country um after World War II okay we
could get into that but they took it as
part of Spoils of War when you lose Wars
there are consequences yeah they then
now are going to give part of it to
Israel and part of it to the Arabs right
to the Jews and the Arabs
uh they give the bulk of it about 70% of
it to the Jews and they give the sort of
desert part of it to the Arabs who
outnumber them right so they gave 70% to
the Zionist yeah and 30 30% to the Arabs
yet uh two strange things happened the
first thing is that the Arab part was
divided up it wasn't one contiguous
piece of country yeah secondly it wasn't
was n given a status as a nation like it
wasn't given you know now you're you're
the you're the Conquering people of the
world right and you're the ones
assigning who's a nation and who's not
so the Arabs are in like
disarray so in contrast to that the
zionists were not in disarray they were
very well organized they were determined
they had great willpower and they
prepared they did all they took all the
asbab of success right the means that
make you successful and when there were
declared a state then the Arabs started
raiding them started fighting them any
cars going by trucks transport they
started Wag the war basically against
them and in order to protect the the
vessels of the nation the highways so
David Ben Gan said all right the the
Border towns we got to mop up any towns
that's in the border so they started
going down all the towns the pal the
Arab towns that are on the border of
this new Israel and and uh Palestine and
they started raiding them and the famous
one was um uh diin this is the famous
one that's quoted all the time in the
histories now the reason I'm saying this
is that not everyone has to be a
historian but this stuff is so out there
it'll only take you three weeks to be
educated on the
subject uh this year called the neba the
1948 catastrophe year of the catastrophe
the IDF now hag now the IDF went through
all of these the these cities many many
many villages many villages and cleaned
them out clean them out clean them out
in one testimony a guy said we were
cooking right with a big oven and a
soldier came into our house and he said
throw your son in the oven he said no he
said then I will he threw the kid in the
oven
is
muham sh
[Music]
you saw the clip yes that's a testimony
right and that and that's actually that
where you're getting that from that's a
Israeli film producer and historians
they put this together they put it
together based off the evidence that was
done by the Israeli himself yeah Teddy
something Israel perception of itself is
of a very decent liberal uh peaceloving
country uh which was surrounded by
predatory Arabs and it had no choice but
to stand up and defend itself so this is
a defensive war and uh there is great
reluctance to look at the dark side of
this war particularly at the ethnic
cleansing that happened in
1948 the broader historical context for
this film
is the ethnic cleansing of Palestine uh
in
1948 uh over 500 Villages were Arab
Villages were destroyed
750,000 Palestinians were made refugees
Benny Morris counted 28 massacres of
which tantura is only one so it's not an
isolated episode that's called the
document is called tentura that's also
in uh the original testimony of that is
in 1948 the movie or the documentary wow
so very vicious things happen but look
you know what's interesting this uh I
often see this projection of them these
certain people um doing these evil and
disgusting things and now they're trying
to project it as if you know we heard
this thing and they put this stuff out
there that certain people are doing this
they try to put it on uh certain uh
resistance group but then they're the
ones that are actually doing it and
there's no evidence now that because I
think this was also an accusation that
now there was someone putting it was a
reverse was was was was accusation was
made and what we seen is there's a lot
of accusations made but all the footage
is one way like the actual evidence the
phys the accusations are just words
right but the actual footage is all
coming out of one place like it's all
coming out of RZA so uh to see why the
Palestinians are
inflamed okay why they have a made a
grievance these things don't go away
just cuz it happened in the past doesn't
mean it's going to go away and the one
who decides if it's going to go away is
the one who's attacked right so the if
you have a chain of generation after
generation who carry the knowledge that
this happened to us carry the belief
that this is oppression that needs to be
redressed and carry the desire to fix
things you can't ever say oh enough time
has past let bygones be bygones and
which is something that many people say
say oh hold on you're taking us down a
path of history and we're going down
that R why don't we just let bygones be
bygones and Live Well the answer to that
is that you don't get to decide that the
victim side get to decide that right
they're the ones who get to decide
listen enough time has passed we all
moved on right and so uh it's you know
it's one of those claims that's repeated
often oh come on just let it go let's
all start living right it's not up to
you to decide that and clearly the
Palestinian people the Arab people and
the Muslims overall all Muslims have not
let it go they haven't let it go and it
all starts in in what you're going to
see you're talking about the NBA now the
nakba yeah no one's Let It Go no one's
let all of this abuse go you think um a
root of that is because there's a denial
of it also there there's a denial of it
and and there's no remorse for it
because you've seen a lot of these
soldiers who are interviewed they're you
would think they're like in their 80s
90s and they're laughing about it
do you see clips of them they proud of
it yeah you see they're like look we
were stupid you know please forgive us
repen of remorseful yeah you see that
and you see some people who have a
conscience but a little too late too
little too late with that and here's the
thing that when you're dominating and
you clearly are dominating you really
should be smart about it fill the
bellies of the people give them some
careers right give him some
opportunities maybe the next generation
will soften that's like the right way to
do this Elon Musk made a really good
point yeah did you see Elon Musk saying
Elon Musk was saying we can go ahead and
uh let's play the clip so you can see
what he's talking about and it kind of
goes in line with what you're saying
deploy acts of
kindness yeah conspicuous acts of
kindness that that with that are
unequivocal meaning they can't be
somehow because hosel then their
response will be oh it's a trick
therefore you have to counter how how is
it not a trick this ultimately fights
the broader force of hatred in the in
the region yes and I'm not sure who said
it apocryphal saying but an eye for the
for an eye makes everyone blind now now
that neck of the woods they really
believe in the whole eye for an eye
thing
um but I mean you really have if if
you're not going to just
outright commit genocide like against an
entire people which obviously would not
be acceptable to to really shouldn't be
AC acceptable to anyone um then you
you're going to leave basically a lot of
people alive who subsequently you know
hate Israel so really the question is
like how for for every Hamas member that
you kill how many did you create MH and
if you create more than you killed
you've not succeeded that's the you know
the real situation there um and it's
safe to say that if you know
um if you know if if you kill somebody's
child in
Gaza you You' you've made at least a few
uh Hamas members who will die just just
to kill an
Israeli that's the situation
so but but I mean this is one of the
most contentious subjects one could
possibly discuss but but I I think if if
the if the goal ultimate is some sort of
long-term peace
one has to be look at this from
standpoint of over time are there more
or fewer um terrorists being
created he covered everything there
essentially that that we were talking
about what we were talking about now
yeah when when we look at these pictures
um b a girl 5-year-old girl she's crying
her eyes out uh a boy now he's got two
legs uh cut off right because now
supposedly now there's a type of bomb
that releases blades and that took the
legs off of a boy and his family's
holding him up right when now he's
got uh no legs so you can twist that if
you're the IDF if you're Israel if
you're the Israel Lobby in America if
you're like Ben Shapiro you can twist
that all you want that oh they put human
Shields right or the Hamas has a a
hospital in the base their their bunker
is in the basement or of the hospital it
doesn't matter if you twist it it's not
changing the reality that you just
created more hatred against you this is
not a smart policy the smart policy is
Elon Musk is saying Mercy yeah the smart
policy is show Mercy show some mercy and
and it doesn't even have to be genuine
if you're totally political then you
know that money uh a bright future a
career right uh wealth that's going to
make people not want to be militaristic
right why is it that America's committed
so many atrocities but against Vietnam
there are Vietnamese Americans
against African-Americans and against
Afric there are African-Americans
against Arab Iraqis against Afghanistan
they're all living here in America no
one's rising up not just that it's the
the you can't they don't want to they're
living happily right the smart way to go
about things is not to create more
hatred against you and it doesn't have
to be from a truly you know uh Goodwill
and some kind of religious spiritual
just purely political mhm soften these
people up fatten them up let them have
too much to
lose right uh most regimes in these
small countries where like small
monarchical family Rules a whole country
they take n 50% of the wealth for
themselves but they fatten up the city
citizenry I mean you go to some of these
countries they hardly pay anything for
gas food is cheap like they're living it
up I met a Jordanian one time in the
Arab Spring and we said hey when is your
turn when is Jordan he said no no no
we're never rising up right he says uh I
get 17 grand dollars 17,000 equivalent
of $177,000 a year from the government
right and I live off that for 6
months when it's summertime I come here
into to America to Jersey I drive the
ice cream truck around right and that
covers the other rest of the my my
expenses right I hardly have to work
right so he loves his King why because
his King fattened him up right so uh
same concept uh what you can bend the
truth in your imagination as much as you
can and try to convince everybody that
no the the they put human Shields
they're sacrificing their babies they
instigated this on purpose so we can
punch them back uh Weinstein is one of
these people with this imagination um
it's not going to change the reality
that you just created three four more
generations of hatred I I like what what
you said um you said this is very clever
it was very clever this um whole term
that they got um right to defend
themselves yeah the right to defend
ourselves also in the middle of the
fight people walked in this is what the
this is what the world was October 7th
people haven't seen an Israel Palestine
conflict for a while like a big one for
a while all of a sudden all these new
eyeballs on the conflict and they're
seeing one party punch the other okay
and the other party say oh we got the
right to defend ourselves but
rewind and in historical things
rewinding 50 years is like half a page
like in history books 100 years is half
a page rewind a little bit and you see
who's the real aggressor and this this
this line I think is extremely
intelligent marketing Ploy and elbl
always us that's what you mentioned a
marketing Ploy it's it's a ploy it's
it's a snuck premise in there right it's
a snuck premise in there where the
premise is I'm the victim the premise is
uh in this conflict I'm the one being
aggressed upon so the man just is
walking out he just raped this woman
beat almost beat her to death he walks
he's almost like out the door and she
jumps up puts her claws in his back yeah
and now that's a picture we get the
picture you got that's a picture that
goes on TMZ but he just raped her beat
her broke in the house yeah he stuffed
his pockets with all her money yeah can
that be a ferris that's a that's that's
an example and uh or you see a guy um
break throwing a rock at at a car or or
chasing after someone it looks like he's
the aggressor hold on but that's my car
yeah right that is literally my car and
I can't tell you how many people have
gone and taking pictures of homes with
Israelis living in it and show oh that
was my grandparents home this was my
parents w we got ton of the I mean
thousand of these stories lot of stories
like this so now you got a guy chasing
down a car right and and banging on it
and he looks like the aggressor right he
looks like the bad guy but rewind the
tape a little bit that was his car mhm
right that was his car he just got
pummeled his car stolen and that guy's
driving off acting civilized yeah so uh
point being again with these guys you
can act civilized you could try to
distort reality as much as you can but
you can't
alter what the reality is on the ground
C can we just uh so going back to where
we started before 1948 and I've had uh
re rabbis that I've spoken to they
testified to this this is documented
this is someone who wants to
academically look at this uh before 1948
I don't know how many years before
before the whole Zionist movement Jews
Christians and Muslims the rabbis
telling me and you know this uh this is
in the books that this was a peaceful
environment M between the three is that
correct it was a peaceful environment
and I'll tell you why because Islam has
a mill concept which is that Islam being
the last of the three religions and I I
really hope uh like well-meaning
Christians and and and Jews listen to
this Islam being the last three
religions has a law on how to govern the
other two religions if they live under
you right now J Judaism being the first
of the three religions logically cannot
possess that right Judaism when the law
came uh uh to to Moses the world was
possessed of monotheists and pagans
that's it two camps that's it um there
was no concept of
monotheists but what we would say
abrogated abrogated meaning God brought
a new law which means you stop following
the Old Law we respect it we honor it
like having a passport this is my
childhood passport I keep it for memory
sake right but I can't show it to
customs my childhood passport we all
have like 10 passports eventually in
your life you're going to have many
passports but it's a nice document you
keep it show your kids what you look
like when you were young but that's it
you don't use it anymore the technology
is different right scans differently it
has different yes ways to be protected
and all that uh from counterfeit so
that's how we view the previous two
faiths right Christianity and Juda they
were altered the books were not
protected if we go further I mean this
is another topic but from the first man
that submission and surrender to one God
that was Islam right it's all Islam by
the meaning of submission to one God yes
and then man manmade religions came up
they had so even this is now acknowledge
that there's laws in the sh Sharia God's
law to protect these they have rights
yes these two they can't have a house
senate come and vote and take away their
rights can we can and in it's in the
Quran and in the sayings of the Prophet
peace be upon Him set in stone that
these two abrogated religions while we
hold them to be abated they do have a
status with us because they are
attributed to prophet Abraham and they
do talk about Prophet Jesus and Mary and
Moses and the Quran says you know the
these temples and places of worship that
utter the name of Allah right just the
fact they utter the name of Allah not
some pagan gods that is the reason that
they're given these respects right and
this is historically proven Jerusalem
the salahu you got omad one of the Cs of
Islam came in and protected the churches
how many 800 years keys of the churches
are in the Muslims hands as let me give
you the story please our second khif
khif is like the the successor yeah is
the prophet peace be upon Him Abu Bakr
Omar yeah Omar comes and he goes to
Jerusalem yeah and the Muslims at this
point have expanded and he arrives at
Jerusalem goes to the patriarch there
and where is their their Center their
church is the Church of the Holy Seer
yes Church of the Holy Seer he there he
meets the patriarch of Jerusalem
patriarch of
Jerusalem uh knows and has the keys to
the furthest mosque or M the third
holiest uh mosque in Islam by the words
of the Prophet peace be upon him now at
that time the Christians had no need of
it it was not their Temple was not their
Church they had the Church of the Holy
supper a little bit away from that may a
mile or something not even a long
distance was uh an abandoned mosque an
abandoned uh building now Omar said this
is the mosque that is the sacred
mosque and so the the the man gave him
the keys and he that was sophronius
right yes the the the the patriarch yes
so he says take here are the keys and
come into our church and offer your
prayers here out of respect yeah now
Omar says that thinks that if I pray
here Muslims in the future may say now
this is like a sacred spot sem think
about that now this is really profound
he refused to pray there and he said not
out of disrespect to your church but to
protect the church but to protect your
church wow and he prayed across the
street and the Muslims built a small
musk there it's called Masjid Omar and
it's right across from the Church of the
Holy he could have prayed in the MOs
than Muslims of today day to say oh
that's ours now exactly cuz he prayed
there and we're going to confiscate and
take it over exactly we he's thinking
ahead he's thinking ahead wow and we
also we have these laws we have rules of
expansion in Islam we don't deny that
Islam expands but there are strict rules
so what are some of these strict rules
if a city let's say submits to you
because the Empire is expanding and the
city knows it's going to be gobbled up
right if that City surrenders to you
okay and they say okay we join your
Empire now build mosqu call the you kill
all the women kill you do like they emac
now you can't touch anything Nei nor can
the government take a single piece of
land so listen to this story we had a
scholar in
Islam uh IM nawi and before him many
scholars I can't even remember their
names but in Iraq there was a village in
Iraq that submitted mhm they said
Muslims we know you're coming we're not
even going to put up a fight okay come
in and theyve joined the darl Islam or
the Abode of Islam or the the the um at
just as a body Poli they have to become
Muslim right but they're can you
translate this as House of Peace yeah
yeah th this this protected Abode that
is submitting to God's law yeah and
so the governor at that time Muslim
governor saw a beautiful plot of land
that's farming and everything yeah he
said all right well we're now we rule
that's ours I'll take it the scholars
said you're not allowed to take it right
you're not allowed to take this grab a
land grab you can't do it now you can't
do it because like they're doing now
over here like the Zion is doing land
grabs no cuz you they submitted to you
right so you're not take now listen to
this there was a market there yeah the
scholar asked where do you guys get your
fruit and vegetables from he said from
that land he went back and he told his
family nobody ever go and buy from that
market that is unlawful food for us mhm
it's unlawful because we grab those
people's land and he would refuse to eat
the crops that came from those lands so
expansion has rules point being is that
the rules of expansion and governance in
Judaism cannot possibly do not include
how to govern Christians how to govern
Muslims it doesn't include it doesn't
include that right Islam the Sharia of
Islam does give rules what happens when
you conquer a land and you are now the
governors of Jews and Christians and
this is with Justice we have to rule
them with Justice and here is the
justice for them is in all civil matters
between you and yourselves Christians
you appoint a leader he governs your
courts unless you aggress against the
musl your you have a dispute with a
Muslim then it goes to Islamic courts
but otherwise this is the mill Mill is a
small group right so Christians you got
your your little area and you have your
Governor now there's one rule because
Islam is governed by the
sh God's law the the precondition of
that is you have to believe in God's law
right nobody could come and say Hey I
want to be a governor uh in the state of
Illinois but I don't believe in Illinois
Law well you're not you can't be
Governor then right so you have one
condition you cannot
rule unless you're a Muslim you could
take different positions you could take
different Minister positions but you
cannot rule because you don't believe in
the law right the moment you say okay
now I believe in the muham there's
nothing worthy of worship except one God
the Creator and Muhammad is his
messenger okay and this law in the Quran
this is the law how we supposed to live
now you can rule at Jesus's time you
would have said Jesus is the messenger
yeah that same statement and mo Moses
the messenger at that time just to so
people get get a better understand
correct at that time see the way it is
is Messengers are sent every messenger
that comes the Quran tells us every
messenger that comes comes with the law
suitable for his era humans change
unlike cats and dogs cats are cats dogs
are dogs but humans are always changing
our society's growing different things
are happening discoveries so the laws
cannot be the same every era MH so God
sent laws to Adam there was a law for
Adam specifically first man Adam first
man for example what was the law to Adam
you cannot marry your twin but you can
marry your sibling right and when Allah
says that you can do something you
cannot do something it's immediately
created in a person a hatred for it in
his Instinct so that's how now it's
populated the race yeah that's how you
but one generation later you can't do
that it's canceled now you cannot do the
same thing the next Prophet comes he
says okay God has brought a new law you
don't need to marry siblings anymore you
can't marry siblings right now Moses has
a law you have to follow that law when
Jesus comes we have to follow him the
Quran says oh Messengers I take an oath
upon you if any new messenger comes you
leave off what you were doing and you
follow him mhm okay if the messengers
were told that imagine them the
followers M so Islam's rule on governing
Jews and Christians and in India they
govern pagans yeah right is that you
have your own courts you have your own
societies you can even have your own
Marketplace whatever you want but you
are not going to rule because you don't
believe in this law that's why I
factiously said I have the solution for
for Israel yes take the whole country
make every Arab there a citizen and
apply sh
you're reverse Shia that live be happy
have make money no politics no ruling
you can be part of the Senate you could
be involved in the government but you're
not ruling tell tell me this uh for the
essence of time now so we went back uh
the history there there's this nakba
that I think it's even in the state
there it's against the law to mention is
that correct I wouldn't be surprised I
don't know as a fact but I wouldn't be
surprised we see if we can fact check
this but I think this is uh from doing
so many interviews there's so many
things that have come to me but this is
something I can check but so this is
kicking it off and you recommended a
great documentary this documentary of
1948 it's called con uh creation and
conflict and conflict so people can see
now at one point living in peace
together Jews Muslims and Christians
living in peace together we have a
history of being able to protect the
churches protect the places of worship
to now land grabs starting to happen
yeah and we touched upon that land grabs
people are coming in even the Jews at
that time were like hold on for the
Zionist coming in what are you guys
planning to do the head the head of the
the head Rabbi at that time was against
this MH and they were also now worried
because you're going to disrupt our
peace so they're coming to land grabs
and then militias and and how we started
now these these terrorist groups
classified by the government website
hagon and
arago they kick off now and you have
total annihilation of because the common
claim is that they came in and then they
all the Arab countries they combined to
try to uh fight this off and to take uh
extinguish them it's always been Jew
vers Muslim Jew vers Muslim they're
trying to extinguish them they won and
that's the common uh story yeah and and
to show so it's a lie it's a lie in the
sense that there was no people there
that's also another lie yeah a land
without a people people a land so that's
another lie might show some footage here
you can see right here that now two
former American vessels carrying nearly
4,000 Jewish refugees arrive at the Port
of hia Palestine jammed like cattle on
the rusty craft the fugitives end their
Bleak Voyage which began at a Black Sea
port and we went from Italy to Palestine
it was not Israel yet it was Palestine
yeah what how did you get you went by
boat by boat we went to Israel when
Israel was not Israel yet two testimony
to the good relations Is that in the
movie 1948 there is one Village yeah
where the Jewish governor of the village
the governor is Jewish yes he is the one
telling the Muslims we live together
don't leave right the Muslims are
fleeing for their lives the Palestinians
Arabs are fleeing for their lives so a
Jewish Governor yeah and just like now
what we're seeing they're fleeing for
their lives yeah they're fleeing for
their lives and this Jewish governor was
saying hey I'm not responsible for this
right he's a old he's lived before the
Zionist came in uh I'm not responsible
for this stay this is your city I want
to try to protect you right I'll
negotiate on your behalf so also in the
name of fairness there are uh plenty of
rabbis who are against Zionism this is
what blows my mind here this is very
important Norman figl I just interviewed
him he's someone whose parents survived
the Holocaust he's putting his neck on
the line he's out there he's one of the
most proficient people academics in this
area you have Jewish Israeli historians
rabbis or Orthodox rites who are also
coming out and speaking against this
Injustice why would they for what what's
the gain yeah I mean they in their in
their books I think they have from the
spiritual perspective they have it that
mankind is not supposed to initiate yes
Israel right uh it's supposed to be
divinely initiated by the M I think they
pronounce it in Hebrew the Messiah so
that this is profane this is a profane
movement mhm uh and and and that is uh
the a turai group pretty much that's
their thesis from a purely religious
perspective then you have purely
fair-minded non-religious Jews who are
just as the Quran says some of the
people of the book you can give them a
mountain of gold they'll guard it for
you right and some of them you can't
even give them a coin so from the
liberal side of things you have people
who are uh dead against this and you
have plent I I should recommend everyone
also watch uh documentary called the
general son M pillet yes I've had him on
M pet yes he's another person I didn't
see the movie myself but I want to i'
I've I've been told that I have to see
it that's a that's a book he wrote uh
his father he was in the IDF his uh
father was a general in the Israeli Army
General and he came from a strong
Zionist lineage and his uh
great-grandfather was one of the
original signers of the state of uh
Israel and when you look at the history
of Jews and Muslims when Jews lived
under Muslims where is the history of
pilgrams where is the history of
holocausts where there is none right
there is none because repeat that again
when Jews lived for all this time above
the Mediterranean in Christian lands yes
and below the Mediterranean in North
Africa syriah Egypt uh Iraq so we have a
good contrast there where did the
programs all happen where did the
holocausts all happen where did the
killing of Jews it didn't happen to
Muslim land It All Happened north of the
Mediterranean right it all happened in
Europe and then they they fled
persecution and often times fled to
Muslims in and Open Arms welcomed their
cousins and brought them in is that
correct that's correct and why is this
history this is like almost hidden it's
kind of uh you see some of these uh
people these hate provocators who are
out there they kind of you know they
want to make this like this is Jewish
Muslim Muslims hate Jews they want to
eradicate Jews they push out this
propaganda but the history doesn't show
that the history's totally the opposite
right uh me ask you do you do you want
to annihilate all Jews do you hate Jews
I don't hate all Jews is this what you
preach to your congregation we we don't
we don't hate people just by the
relation by the religion uh we're going
to hate people based upon oppression and
fighting us for our uh uh religion and
our land uh and our lives and that
hatred when we say hatred it has a
technical meaning it's not an emotional
meaning it's a policy it means on this
matter I'm against you I will not
support you I will not fund you right
that's hatred in the Quran it's a policy
right and so to this idea of uh uh
trying to pit the the two together is
not going to fit for many
reasons I want to before we conclude so
we have um so Elon Musk yeah I think uh
Common Sense he's one of the people that
are out there that people look as one of
the most intelligent people out there
and he's saying that show
Mercy show Mercy to the people
have some mercy play the long game some
videos that are coming up now I think
you've shared some of these um we'll
show this real uh quick and we'll
contrast that with with Islam the point
is right here that hasem say do not have
mercy on the children kill all their
children also why there's no difference
between them and their children in 10
years from now these children will
attack you on the
way knows God knows you kill all men and
all
women even babies who
breastfeed
amazing all axes all goats camel
donkeys don't leave anything any memory
from this filthy
Nation so that's what the Torah say
someone is on the way to kill you now or
in a year from now you can kill him even
now a year before you don't have to wait
a minute before you know this person
will kill you statistically that's what
it always constantly repeat so you're
allowed to go and attack him first is to
remember to erase the nation of Amal the
memory of them even not only physically
to erase them from the face of the Earth
anything that remind us about them is
Mitzvah to dismiss and to erase it from
the face of the Earth we assume that
it's the Germans after we see what they
did in Holocaust not only to the Jews to
the whole
world and it's not only the Germans it's
more most of the European countries
that's where a uh to be fair now is he
just refer is he just talking about
history of what happened or how in
context what what do you take from this
uh I believe that's the Deuteronomy
verse and I believe that what he's
referring to is Moses not Moses this
generation never made it to the Holy
Land but the generation after and
supposedly we don't know what's true and
false of the Torah anymore uh but the
quote goes or the law goes erase uh kill
all of them even their kids even their
animals so there's a completely clean
out cleaned out land no people are
usually have you been uh attacked
because uh certain people they bring up
the term hij um Jihad you got to
modernize the Quran give it a new modern
twist interpretation because they'll
quote certain things out of context but
you just put in context you say okay it
makes sense yeah but you know go if if a
Muslim Imam you or somebody was talking
like this even though there's nothing oh
youd
cooked yet he's flourishing in Queens
you he's from your area he's from Queens
yeah have you met him I've never met him
I don't know if he met he meets Gentiles
but uh would you ever sit and talk with
him if I'd like to sit and talk with him
I'll tell you why because he's telling
you as it is he's the type of literal
reading now are there people who have an
interpretation of this maybe maybe not
I'm not a big fan of if if there's an
interpretation it better be clear yeah
I'm not a big fan of let's go around and
figure eights uh here's what I don't I I
don't like when the islamophobes in the
islamophobic industry they they prop up
these actors and they'll insist that we
take an extreme interpretation when the
consensus of scholarship is like no no
no it's this way and they give it the D
or the extreme so I'd rather go with the
the merciful interpretation and then we
can gang up to get this guy more on on
the merciful side well well let me tell
you when you're there's an
interpretation it should be very Crystal
Clear yes right like very crystal clear
that this verse is specific to this
situation the proof being this verse
this verse this verse this verse right
uh I'm not a fan of interpretations that
are complex that means you're bsing me
you're lying you're trying to wiggle
yourself out okay so my question would
be to the rabbis what verse of the Torah
abreg hates that qualifies it limits it
right what and how am I supposed to
understand this verse that's my question
he is a rabbi scholar there are other
Rabbi Scholars right I personally think
that uh the truth is what he said about
the Torah I think that's the the actual
je from wow I think that's a Jewish
belief yeah but I can't uh deny voice
but that's what that explains what's
happening that explains what's happening
in Gaza now I my saying that I believe
that that's he's accurate doesn't
necessarily mean that I'm right I just
from what I've seen where are the
controverses where are the verses that
counter this of the Torah that say okay
okay spare this spare that right don't
kill this don't kill that we have that
clearly in Islam like very clearly in
Islam it's doesn't take uh 2 minutes of
research and you put it up on your show
before of the Prophet P said this this
this this any taper which is explanation
of the Quran is there any anything in
the Quran or Sunnah where gives you a
green light to harm innocent civilians
children women innocent non-combatants
the only person you're allowed to fight
is a combatant in Islam and if a woman
or a priest or a rabbi or a monk or an
elderly person picks up a gun and he
points it at you he's no longer a
civilian he's in Islam you're equivalent
to what would be like a priest or
Rabbi yeah yeah so you're the Learned
person that's what people would come
hopefully some people think so uh but
all of us I think in the west or a lot
of us I could say myself we're always
because they usually they'll anticipate
if you're here they see the priest in
his
outfit yeah yeah yeah I mean we we we we
wear that but sometimes you know we're
still students and we're still learning
but these things are not up for you
know's they don't need eight years of
study to know this stuff these basic
Muslim knows lay Muslim knows this I'll
tell you what they always cite slay them
wherever you see them right and you're
going to see in every T that is a very
simple when you zoom out it is to a
specific period of time right uh after
four months and they were told you know
you have four months to make up your
mind cuz this peninsula is going to be
all Muslims right just the Arab
Peninsula that so that was clearly to
that period of time to that location so
this is in context now fighting the
pagans that one is in a context now
fight those who fight you exactly but
don't transgress the limits uh that a uh
has a context to that period of time to
that location but they'll take this
extract it and try to put like oh right
now today 2023 kill your neighbor yeah
now the sign of a real interpretation is
I can very easily get you the verses
that qualify it abrogate it abgate means
it's no longer law it was aw a policy
for a policy for a period of time it's
no longer a policy right I can clearly
show it to you so my question would be
is that the case uh in the Jewish
religion fair question fair question
let's bring a rabbi and see right uh but
it would explain the nature of what's
Happening wow that Palestine must be
completely cleansed right the or Israel
the whatever that piece of land must be
completely cleansed of every Gentile and
then you have the um the leader of this
group now follower of not Prophet Moses
follower of Theodor herzo who's the the
Prime Minister he's actually quoting the
Bible I heard he's an atheist also like
the herzo but I don't think anybody
someone who believes in in the all
loving most merciful creator of the
heavens and earth is going to do
something like this but he's actually
quoting you saw the um him bringing up
the emcs and quoting the bi the Bible
yeah and then and then so heing cities
why you doing that if you want to commit
a exactly if you're if you're not um
calling upon or or hearkening back to
your holy book why yeah Netanyahu would
call uh Judea and what he recently
called cities in the West Bank said
Judea and some other City using biblical
names why hearken back to the why is
nobody going at why why aren't the
mainstream media why aren't this the uh
the people peace loving you know um
Jesus the prince of peace and all this
coming up forward to condemn this well
you know um it's it's it's so
interesting it's uh polit so Politically
Incorrect to say they're all intertwined
financially mhm and at the end of the
day people make financial decisions
really that's that's the best
explanation of it yeah right at the end
of the day of course it's like
Politically Incorrect to say that
they're they're intertwined but we're
going to start lying and telling uh
pretending that the Ross Childs are not
a trillionaire family that has been
backing Zionism and and and spreading
its Lobby throughout the world right
throughout the uh Western European and
American world and the families like
them right we're going to start try try
to pretend in the name of being you know
not saying the wrong thing that the the
Israel Lobby is not the strongest Lobby
on the Earth right when you have two
authors to I mean you've had PR former
Prime Ministers Who come out and
actually admitted je Israelis themselves
yeah people here are called anti-semitic
what is your response to that as an
Israeli Jew well it's a trick we always
use it when from Europe somebody is
criticizing Israel then we bring up the
Holocaust when in this country people
are criticizing Israel then they are
anti-semitic and the organization is
strong and has a lot of money and the
the ties between Israel and the American
EST Jewish establishment are very strong
like the IND who was it Indonesian prime
minister uh mentioned something like
this before and he said you know they
control everything and then when he was
condemned uh they brought him on CNN and
he said um uh the the guy said you said
this the whole world condemned you you
said they're the most powerful people in
the world and they control the world and
the whole world condemned you he said
well then you just prove my point so
yeah uh but but what you said there's a
former Israeli Jew woman herself who
came out I don't know if You' seen it
and she said yeah this is what exactly
what you're saying there's the I mean
the book The Israel Lobby is this thick
right written by two Jews one from
Harvard one from Chicago here and just
documenting for you the the the depth
right of uh influence that and it goes
without say you can't run for anything
Be A Millionaire be a trillionaire and
not have in some way shape and form
cross paths with this Lobby right you're
going to cross paths with them and they
could crush your political career easily
they could crush your career in
Hollywood easily they could crush your
career in finance and banking very
easily right
and many other things so truth is one
thing and I think a lot of people know
it but at the end of the day people make
financial decisions we're almost out of
time tell me uh another thing that Elon
was saying I think it made a lot of
sense he says the more bombs you drop
what was he saying more you're creating
the resistance Fighters he said for
every Hamas meaning
anti-israel you know Palestinian uh that
you kill you're going to create more
you're three more right four more and
you that sentiment I have to say is is
obviously going to be true right because
when I see these little kids I ask
myself one day she's going to be a
mom one day she's going to be telling
stories to her kids one day they're
going to sit at the table and teach
their kids their politics their beliefs
that's what people do at the dinner
table right one of the secrets of eating
dinner together you transmit your
politics to your kids you transmit your
beliefs to your kids you share stories
of History to your kids what kind of
stories is she going to be telling she's
not going to be telling some kind of
fuzzy wuzzy story she's going to be
telling them these people blew your
uncle's legs off these people killed
your grandma here's the video of me 30
years ago crying in the street and what
do you think that kid's going to do mhm
that's my mom that you guys crying
covered in mud like this crying in a
hospital covered in mud right and
there's no one there crying for for
minutes on end no one to hold her no one
to hug her no one to put a blanket on
top of her and the only adults around
her are equally devastated so how do you
think that kid's going to feel uh people
under marketing cannot penetrate the
home you can Market you can lie you can
cover things over you can pretend they
don't exist you're not going and
changing people's homes and the lie that
this is just Muslims trying to eradicate
Jews we've covered that's a lie it would
have happened a long time ago it would
happened a long time ago in history so
they want freedom Americans can
understand that we live want the
American dream you know freedom Liberty
for all these people want the same thing
they want freedom they want the freedom
to fish to not have two sets of laws for
two different people the right of return
uh someone from New York coming and uh
from your backyard yep uh Ruben Stein I
think he was called you remember that
yeah uh did you see those videos they
had 60 Minutes put out where the soldier
goes and the guys he's sleeping in his
bed yeah they take them hostage in their
own home at any time yeah I mean it's
you can go on and on with the uh the the
different types of Oppression examples
that are you can't be somebody who
supports um is
anti-racist against the apartheid of
South Africa and then pretend you don't
see the same exact thing happening here
because it's it's the same exact thing
and in some cases it's worse yeah so I I
think people are waking up that they're
they're seeing behind this um these
silly excuses that are given you know
that are pared out there but um we
started off with the
uh request for uh our friend Patrick to
go ahead and do the other side to talk
about these uh these groups as he did
with the other ones that we mentioned I
think this is uh hopefully he can give
some he's really good at doing that
putting the statistics and facts yeah I
mean I hope his um uh you know he's he's
a fair-minded guy and I hope he does it
and I know people have friends and
interest that they don't want to offend
but sometimes also when you're a host at
that level of a platform uh in order to
be taken uh you know seriously by people
more seriously he's already taken
seriously but more ser seriously uh when
you're Fair people love fairness be fair
yeah people love fairness and people
they start to look down let you know not
really fully respect someone who's too
agenda oriented everyone has an agenda
and I respect it right let's say he's a
Christian and he's got a Eastern
Orthodox that's what I'm pushing out
fine I respect that but even within an
agenda there's fairness right and even I
noticed my own biases right like I
always cite this Rabbi Yousef M I say
look look what the the Torah says and
people point out to me hold on there's
another Rabbi says the opposite I said
okay fine I personally think he's
representing the Torah properly but I
could be wrong right and there could be
another Rabbi with another
interpretation and it could be very
peaceful after all this so you got to
always like Imam Shafi put it best I
believe I'm right but there's a
possibility I'm wrong MH on certain
matters on matters of discussion certain
matters are not of discussion no one's
going to disagree the Sun comes from the
east or that God is one and there are
five prayers haes in Mecca certain
things no one disagrees on but on
matters of dispute I believe I'm right
but I could be wrong M right and that's
the approach we have to take especially
in political issues where it's up for
grabs and everyone's making claims uh
hopefully uh you guys can share this uh
with our friend Patrick and hopefully he
can put something together like he did
brilliantly with the statistics and all
this other stuff on these these couple
groups that you mentioned be great the
root of what caus these other groups to
come out it's Common Sense thank you
very much my pleasure my pleasure and
thank you guys for tuning in and if you
like to get to the book The Root of the
matter to see really what the purpose of
life is why we've been created to look
at what Muslims what motivates Muslims
in life because a lot of these things
now where we get our values where we get
our principles in is in this book the
Quran give it to you for free go to the
Deen show.com we'll take care of the
postage handling and get it to you so
you can judge for yourself until next
time till then peace be with you assalam
alaykum brothers and sisters we've all
had
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you're not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum